well how did it go when you learned to  drive because you're only 19 right  yeah i'm only 19 turning 20 at the end  of the year uh learning how to drive was  an experience because my first  experience was in like  you know a big parking lot and my only  experience before that was mario kart  as you know as it be like so i was  very surprised that even if you're not  pressing the gas pedal the car still  moves  what's that about like what i thought  yes it keep rolls  why does it keep moving i was very  concerned my dad's like just press the  brake i'm like but i'm not pressing the  gas so why are we moving  we need to stop it doesn't do that in  mario kart oh my god i hope i'm never  driving around you  fair enough that's fair that was awesome  yep i'm still here just waiting for you  to subscribe  if you don't i'll be trapped in this box  forever